May 16 marks the centenary of the ratification
of the Sykes-Picot Agreement.
The Sykes-Picot Agreement was the origin
of the modern Middle East.
It was a secret agreement negotiated by Georges
François Picot and Mark Sykes, respectively
a French and a British diplomat
in order to divide up the Ottoman Empire in the Middle
East after World War I ended.
The British were going to take what is now
Israel, the Palestinian territories, and Jordan,
southern Iraq as well.
The French were going to take an area along
the Mediterranean, as well as much of Syria.
And the Russians—who knew about this—were
going to take Istanbul and the Bosphorus.
Now, the exposure of the secret agreement
was deeply, deeply embarrassing to the French
and the British.
It was exposed after the Bolshevik Revolution
by the Russians, and it was almost like the
Wikileaks scandal of the last century
because you had all the secret maneuverings
behind the scenes exposed, and the Allied
Powers had egg on their face.
They promised the Arabs one thing and were
doing quite another.
A hundred years after Sykes-Picot, should
the borders be redrawn?
Or are we stuck with the legacy of diplomatic
agreements a hundred years ago?
Let us know in your comments, and let us know
any other questions you'd like us to cover
in 60 seconds.